hey there my name is Seth Juarez we're
at the 2015 microsoft research faculty
summit and I'm here with two of our
researchers so tell us about the project
you're working on we were looking at a
bunch of different phone applications
and we noticed they're all reading the
sensors and the sensors have a lot of
noise in them and we wanted to make
devices like the band and your phone
more energy-efficient and we realized
there was no way to trade off accuracy
or efficiency for quality of service
because there was no way to express it
in any of these languages and then we
realized not only sensors have this
problem but machine learning algorithms
are producing approximate answers and
also approximate computing is a new
mechanism for reducing computation to
gain energy efficiency and it also fell
in this peridot so then we're like we
need to start with the programming
language abstractions before we can
build systems that reason about this in
a principled way so let's start with the
actual sensor reading and why it's
inefficient so we're talking about GPS
specifically why is GPS so inefficient
when it comes to battery life so what
happens with GPS is when it needs to
contact a lot of satellites and the more
satellites you get the more accurate is
so that takes time because you know
you're communicating over
noisy channel too many different
satellites and it takes time just to
communicate you know and do the
triangulation itself so so the process
is just very energy if it um greet on
your actual device there's also a notion
of uncertainty with these types of
reading isn't there so when the GPS
takes a reading there's some number of
satellites that are communicating it
each of them has a sense of what time it
is and then there's a delay they have
very accurate clocks but then it arrives
at your phone at different times and so
it can be cloudy a building can be
including one of the satellites and so
when that happens the GPS gets more and
more inaccurate and everyone's had their
car gps tell them that they're driving
in a field or in an ocean and so that's
a case where the GPS can't produce an
accurate accurate reading and right now
when you code one of these applications
like a navigation application you
essentially ignore that data and try to
put yourself on a road but even if you
use good heuristics for getting yourself
back on the highway and out of the ocean
what happens is it's all hand coded and
not principled it and so so we trying to
provide an abstraction that reasons
about the error in these readings
explicitly and makes it easy for
programmers to combine domain knowledge
such as roads the speed you're traveling
and the likelihood that your your phone
is in the ocean which could happen if
you step onto a boat but is unlikely if
the gps is installed in your car so
you're modeling this uncertainty while
at the same time trying to
lessen the toll on the actual battery so
is there a way to actually know where
you are without necessarily having to
ask GPS location is a pretty abstract
concept that many operating systems
would like to provide right in gps is
just a mechanism to estimate your
location right but there are many other
ways and in fact there are many
researchers who spend a lot of time
thinking of very clever ways to estimate
location for instance you can use your
Wi-Fi to try and estimate you know hey
I'm in a building that I recognize I've
been in this building before or maybe I
just use the accelerometer on device i
took a GPS reading say five minutes ago
the accelerometer tells me that the
phone is probably not moved much so I'm
pretty likely to be where I was before
but you'll notice I use the word likely
so there is this notion of distribution
associated with all of these types of
estimates right and so that's what we're
trying to capture in the programming
abstraction where we don't want the
programmer to really have to reason
about what that distribution is right we
want the operating system providing
abstract location service an error is
encapsulated with those particular types
of ways that we would estimate location
so we keep talking about abstraction and
programmer using the abstraction what is
this abstraction look like that you've
been working on for example the GPS
error although what they draw on your
phone is a dot in a circle it's actually
a doughnut so the doughnut around the
point they draw is and there's a little
circle inner circle on the doughnut
which is where you're most likely to be
alright see you so that district the
doughnut distribution is called a rolly
distribution so you can take samples
from there that describe the error and
those are other locations you're likely
to be and then when you make a decision
like to draw a point on a graph or or to
compute how long you've been running
then you want to say how likely is it
that I've been that I'm want to draw it
on this road and then you can explicitly
reason
about the fact that hey this this point
is very accurate according to the gps so
i can trust it or it's not accurate and
so I want to maybe add domain knowledge
like the road where the road is and move
the point to snap to the row so you just
have a simple conditional that says what
to do when when when you want to add
some dimming knowledge so you mentioned
to me earlier that you were language
researchers are you adding types or
language features that will enable this
type of a certainty to be modelled well
yeah we have a generic type in c sharp
and in fact everything is in you know
it's a library in c-sharp our
uncertainty libraries and we so I think
it's best explained with with again GPS
example right so suppose that I want to
compute how fast I'm going my speed
using to GPS samples time I've taken it
one gps sample taken at time t0 and
another one taking at time t1 you know i
would take those due to gps locations
compute the distance and then use you
know your distance equals rate times
time to compute my rate so what we do
rate is a you know in that program that
i just described rate is a float or a
double right but what we're going to
provide is because the original we're
going to give a traction over location
as an uncertain location and we've done
the appropriate operable operator
overloading in our types so that you
compute actually an uncertain float for
your rate right and so as a consequence
whenever you want to now act on that
data for instance use it in a
conditional to say whether or not I'm
you know if my speed is greater than
five miles an hour i might want to you
know post something to the user's
display that actually that speed greater
than five miles an hour we use implicit
type conversions to actually do a
hypothesis test and try and
statistically evaluate whether or not we
have enough evidence to prove whether or
not you're going faster than five miles
an hour so our run time you know so we
have a library that lets a programmer
express this and then a runtime that
implements that semantics that's awesome
so as researchers what's the future of
this kind of reason what are you guys
doing in the future with this stuff so I
think there's a lot of challenges so
this this idea of domain knowledge
composition I think it's a very general
principle a lot of times you know much
like when you produce a library you
don't know
you make a certain surface of API calls
that people can use and depending on how
a particular client uses that those that
surface you can do them all of
optimizations I think the same thing
goes to set be said with with this idea
of uncertainty right i mean again going
back the cheapest abstraction people use
that location service in various
different ways and coming up with really
efficient ways to encode that domain
knowledge of how they're actually using
that and then make the actual what
amounts to probabilistic inference
faster under the hood we're really doing
probabilistic inference which is a
generally very hard problem and so we
need to come up with smart ways to take
what the programmer knows about their
domain and help and help will hopefully
come up with faster and efficient
implementations of that problem was the
conference but more and more application
programmers are dealing with estimated
values they're consuming the being
search results they're consuming machine
learning algorithms they're consuming
sensors so if they have to have a PhD in
statistics in order to correctly build
applications with these estimated values
either they're going to produce your
junk because they're not going to do it
at all because they're going to just
give up and treat them as if they're
facts or they're going to or it's going
to be an arduous process and you're
going to always have to have a
statistics PhD on your application
building team and so what we're trying
to do is provide some abstractions where
we bury the complications that we've
been talking about in the runtime and
the
language implementation but the
abstractions that the programmer gets to
use even though we probably could have
done a better job making them seem
straightforward are actually a lot more
straightforward than anything they could
do and then we want to embed them in
languages like C sharp Java C++ because
then they can be widely applicable in
application languages that lots of
people are using today because right now
there are some approaches that have
similar goals as as we do in terms of
representing uncertainty and but called
probabilistic programming languages but
we're kind of we kind of just are a
subset of that that is also programmable
for average programmers rather than
requiring both a PhD in statistics and
machine work well thanks so much for
spending some time with us thanks for
watching and we'll catch you next time
take care